(audience applauds)
- Hi.
- [Kelly] You probably...
- I match your pink.
- [Kelly] I know, you
match the set, you do,
but oh my God, you probably,
I always know girls with
curly hair, naturally
are always like, "I
wish it were straight".
Your hair is so wonderful.
- Thanks.
- [Kelly] It's like a
freaking hair commercial,
you just walked out here.
- That's so nice.
- Yeah.
- I, I, I straightened it.
I chemically straightened it
for years and then I gave up.
(Emmy laughs)
- Oh my God, I, Ugh, I'm so
jealous, it's so beautiful.
- I also had a daughter and I was like,
you know I should just start
wearing my hair the way it is.
Why should I tell her that
she should make her hair look
anything other than how
it grows out of her head?
So I was like...
- Absolutely, yeah.
- You know what?
(audience applauds)
That's for her.
- And you possibly, found
that becoming a mother,
there is less time to straighten it out.
(Kelly laughs)
- Wait, time, there's time?
- [Kelly] It's gone,
everything's gone, yeah.
- This is my first time
I'm actually ever away,
I've ever been away from her.
- Oh no, are you doing okay?
I remember I freaked out.
- I'm great.
- But you're, no...
- [Kelly] There's also that half of you,
no, that half of you, that's just like,
"Oh, my God, this is what it's
like to just pee on my own".
Like, you know, there's just,
(audience laughs)
there's things that you do
that you forgot were yours.
- Peeing is amazing.
- [Kelly] Yes, without someone...
- Also, I'm used to peeing
while wearing the BabyBjorn.
- [Kelly] Yep.
- And if you've ever tried
to get under the Bjorn,
to unbutton the top
one, you can get it down
and then, you do whatever
you have to do, finish
and then getting up,
you have to get the jeans
under the Bjorn again.
- Yeah, which is more difficult.
- It's a whole situation.
- [Kelly] Than the off, yes.
- Of course I miss her, but
I'm also not covered in yogurt.
So, there's that.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
- No, it's also awesome to
just have like, me time.
That's so important, but how
do you think you've changed,
like since becoming a mom?
- Well, I think I'm okay with mess now.
I kind of have to be because, and I,
and I try to remember that just
because the house is a mess,
doesn't mean I'm a mess.
- Oh.
- Which I saw in a meme and I
remind myself of constantly.
(Emmy chuckles)
- [Kelly] I don't know
if that's true, Emmy.
(Kelly laughs)
Because if my closet's a mess,
inside I'm not doing well,
because I'm a very clean person.
- [Emmy] Oh, yes.
- I'm anal, my kids probably hate me,
because I'm like, "Why
don't you just put it away?
You just got it out and played with it".
Now, they're not, it was
different when they were younger.
- My girl, my girl is 10 months, so.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah, she's almost a year.
- We're, yeah.
(audience laughs)
- No, my house was a mess then,
I just mean mine are five and seven now
and I'm like, "Oh no,
if you could get it out,
you can put it up".
But no, when they're that age,
you're just kind of, like fun,
because you want them to crawl,
you want them to do all the things,
so you don't really mind it.
But are you going to have,
speaking of 10 months,
that's coming up on a year.
Are you excited about the first party?
- I am, it goes so fast.
I can't even, it's like I don't understand
how it's been a year.
Also, like the first six months
are just like a blackout.
I'm not sure what happened.
- [Kelly] Oh, man.
- It like, stuff was
healing, there was milk.
- Yeah.
- [Emmy] I don't know, stuff happened.
- But no, I feel like I'm not
going to have a huge party
for her first birthday because
it's her first birthday.
- [Kelly] She won't remember it.
- Right, right.
- Yeah.
Just take really good pictures
and make it look like you did.
Oh my God, it was epic,
you know, the pictures.
She'll just see that, you know.
- No.
- Oh, my God, you should've been there.
Like, and it was like,
nothing's happening.
- No, no, no, no.
- They won't remember it, yeah.
I put all this hard
work in the first time.
- I don't remember, I
don't remember my birthdays
until I was like five or six.
- [Kelly] Oh, my God.
I don't remember birthdays
until I was like 10.
Like, I don't even remember
anything before 10.
- Well, I remember one
because I had a pool party
and I was the only one skinny dipping.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- Oh, my God, we would've been friends.
My mom always tried to keep clothes on me.
I don't know why I liked taking them off.
- [Emmy] I did not believe in clothing.
- [Kelly] Me neither.
- They're so encumbering,
why would I wear them?
- [Kelly] Yeah, this
is how it was intended.
- Shoes as well, why?
- I don't know, but in the grocery store
my mom said I would just
start taking my clothes off.
(Emmy and audience laugh)
Like I was young, but
like, I was just like,
"Yeah, this feels, this feels weird".
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- That was a fun party,
everybody got a show.
- It was interesting
because I don't remember
ever feeling like shame about my body,
but all the other kids were,
thought it was odd that
I was suddenly naked.
- This was me, I never felt...
- And then I thought, "Oh,
maybe it's odd to be naked".
- Yeah, which is wrong, they ruined that.
(audience applauds)
I've got to say I started
the series "Angelyne".
So, it looks great, it
looks one, super fun,
because you look like a
completely different human.
(audience applauds)
- [Emmy] Yeah, it's fun.
- [Kelly] And that's got to be fun,
just transforming like that.
I know as an actor, in general,
you transform into a
character all the time,
but I just mean like physically,
you look like a different human.
And also, I knew that you
were a musical beforehand,
but I, it was a very cool thing to...
Like this is who you play.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] This is Angelyne.
- [Emmy] Uh-huh, the Billboard Queen.
- [Kelly] So, for people
that don't know though,
she's the Billboard Queen
and I had no idea who she was before this.
- [Emmy] Oh, really?
- I grew up in Texas, so I never knew.
But, so she was this like billboard,
and obviously you want
to know who that is, so.
(audience laughs)
So, can you explain to everybody else
that didn't know who Angelyne was?
- Sure, yeah.
Well, in the 1980s,
if you were at all in L.A.
suddenly there were these billboards
that started popping up
everywhere of this woman,
who kind of looked like a
hyper-sexualized Barbie doll.
With her name Angelyne and a
phone number for management
and it's like, there were a
couple of billboards initially,
and then there were
hundreds of billboards.
And even at her peak,
there was a 10 story wall,
at the corner of Hollywood and Vine.
And everybody knew who she was.
I first saw her when I was 13,
when I came out to
audition for pilot season
and I saw one of these billboards
and I started asking people,
"Who is this Angelyne person?"
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And they would be like,
"Well that's just Angelyne, she's famous".
And I would say, "What, what does she do?"
And they would say, "What
do you mean she's Angelyne?"
So, and the more I kind of
got fixated on this idea,
of like, well, what is she
famous for? Where is she from?
And everyone had these
wild stories about her.
Like, that, that she had some rich guy
who paid for the billboards
or she was from space or
there were actually 12 of her
and they kept like changing them out.
And she drives around in a pink Corvette
and she'll sell you merch
with her face on it,
out of the trunk of her car.
(Kelly laughs)
Or she'll, you can buy a ride along,
where you get in her car
and like, drive around the block with her.
And she represents kind of, hot pink
and good luck and positivity.
And she kind of roared
into L.A. and took it over.
She was kind of like, she's a
living, breathing work of art.
And she's kind of curated
her life that way,
she kind of, was Instagram
before Instagram.
- I was going to say like an
influencer, almost before.
- [Emmy] Yeah, she kind of invented that.
She...
- Yeah.
- Kind of, came up with this identity
and chose it for herself and
she lives that every day.
And I think she's kind of incredible.
- It's in, it's very
interesting, the character,
because I was like, "Wow".
Even how she talks to the, I
don't want to ruin anything,
but even how her relationship
with the guy and the band,
like all this stuff, like how she kind of,
and then I love how it's like,
how one person sees a situation
and the other one is like,
"That's not how it happened".
And then, you see the same situation,
but it's completely different
in how people remember it.
- Well, that's what I
thought was so interesting
about all the stories that
I had heard about her,
where they were wildly contradictory.
And I started thinking about how fame is,
like a fame machine and
how an icon is built.
Like the mythology of that,
how you have all these
contradicting narratives
about where somebody's
from or what they represent
or who they really are.
And, and to kind of,
juxtapose all of those
and show that there is no
one real truth to anything,
is kind of, really interesting.
- Yeah and how many truths
there are out there,
because you don't know the real one.
So, my favorite part though,
was the whole band thing.
Like when you start, like,
that was actually, very cool.
Like, when y'all were doing the whiskey
and like all those things.
- [Emmy] Yeah, she was a musician.
- [Kelly] She was a
musician, she had an album.
- She was also in films, yeah.
She's actually got
really cool, punk music.
- Did you have fun playing her on stage?
Because it looked like
a fun role to like...
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Like, you know, just
emulate her like on stage,
because you were, you were
like totally on stage.
Like it's, oh you're very flirty,
like her character's
very flirty, very sexual
and like, but like kind of not.
Like, she's like this innocent thing,
but like, kind of showing
something that she's not.
- Well, she says that she
idolizes the Barbie doll,
because the Barbie doll feels no pain.
You can stick her with
things and she won't get hurt
and she can't get sick.
- I remember that line and I got so sad.
- [Emmy] And I was, I think
that's so fascinating,
because it's something
that is so beautiful
and so beloved by children
and also invulnerable.
- Yeah.
- And the idea of vulnerability as a woman
and how she kind of,
uses her kind of, femininity
and her sexuality to get people off guard.
- [Kelly] Yeah, oh she does, yeah.
- [Emmy] And to have the upper hand
and have control of the
world and the situation.
I think there's a lot of power.
- And really control of that mystery.
- Yeah.
- Yeah and she never kind of,
contradicts what people say about her,
because...
- She leans in.
- It only helps kind of,
build this mythology.
- Even the bad review
thing, that was so funny,
I was like, she totally, I'm like,
"I want that filter", like.
(audience laughs)
- Where like somebody writes
about you and you're like,
"Well, they're writing about me".
- Yeah.
- They think I'm awesome
enough to write about.
It was just like the most positive outlook
and I was like, "We all need that".
So, what did it feel like though,
the first time that you
saw yourself as Angelyne?
Did it kind of help you
to get more in character?
- Well, it's such a wild transformation,
and the makeup and hair team
and the prosthetics artists
and everyone who worked on this,
were, I mean, some days
it took three hours,
Some days it took seven hours
before I would even go to work.
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh.
- [Emmy] So, it's really, I mean, that's,
I mean, clearly not what,
I'm not blessed enough
to look like that.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
But they did that and
I've got to tell you,
I thought it was, the first
time I looked in the mirror
and saw, not myself.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It was scary at first
because you're so used to like,
the context of recognizing yourself.
- Yeah.
- [Emmy] And then there was
this incredible liberation
and I felt so empowered in the body.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's cool.
- That if there, yeah,
after like six months of it,
I was like, "Is this
better? Should I do this?"
(Kelly and audience laugh)
It's very...
- No, that just looked heavy and like,
maybe back surgery in the future.
- [Emmy] It was quite heavy.
(Kelly laughs)
It was quite heavy and she's
a pint size, little thing, so.
- I know, I loved the
performance part though.
I thought that was the coolest like, part.
Like, it was really, really cool.